following johnny depp's victory in his
defamation case against amber hurt a
juror is speaking out and explaining in
detail how the jury came to their
decision do you find that mr depp has
proven all the elements of defamation
answer yes the juror who's remaining
anonymous and identifying as one of five
men on the jury told abc news that a lot
of her story didn't add up to him the
crying the facial expressions that she
had the staring at the jury all of us
were very uncomfortable i'm not sitting
in this courtroom snickering
i'm not sitting in this courtroom
laughing smiling making snide jokes i'm
not
this is horrible
this is painful
and this is humiliating for any human
being
to go through the juror says that
because heard would answer one question
while crying and then two seconds later
seem ice-cold some of the jury called
her emotion crocodile tears he also
shares that several of them saw heard as
the aggressor not depp a lot of the jury
felt what he was saying at the end of
the day was more believable he just
seemed a little more real in terms of
how he was responding to questions his
emotional state was very stable
throughout no one deserves to live like
that not her not me not anyone
so i just wanted
a smooth
exit for both of us and one factor in
the jury's verdict that heard had not
donated the 7 million divorce settlement
to charity like she promised sitting
here today ms heard you still haven't
donated the 7 million
divorce settlement to charity isn't that
right
incorrect i pledged the entirety
of
the juror then references the video of
amber revealing on a uk talk show that
she gave all the money away while using
the phrases i donated it and it's gone
he says but the fact is she didn't give
much of it away at all they played a
tape where you stayed on the air that
you have donated it do you think that
raised questions as to your credibility
with the jury
i made a pledge
and
that pledge
is made over time by its nature yeah the
divorce settlement was also a hot topic
in herd's first sit-down interview
earlier this week where nbc news's
savannah guthrie brought up her
perceived credibility with the jury you
know that everybody thinks that you've
donated it not that you've pledged it so
for the jurors sitting there
do you think they felt like that was you
getting caught in a lie
i i don't know because so much of the
i feel like so much
of the trial was meant to
cast aspersions on who i am as a human
my credibility to call me a liar and in
every way you can and that was the trial
it was a credibility contest and that
was it but in the end the juror says
they sided with death because they
followed the evidence ultimately what i
think is truthful was that they were
both abusive to each other i don't think
that makes either of them right or wrong
but to rise to the level of what she was
claiming there wasn't enough or any
evidence that really supported what she
was saying
[Music]
you